the tungle app for iPhone puts the power
of a worldwide Exchange Server in the
palm of your hand just sync up your
calendar and you're ready to go the app
lets you share calendars and easily
schedule meetings with your contacts no
matter what calendar they use or company
they're in you can even see at a glance
if they're free or busy and know the
perfect time to place a
call for easy scheduling just tap to see
schedules of your network contacts bring
a few together to find potential meeting
time
s planning a lunch meeting filter out
all other
times pick a few slots to propose or
give it a shake and the app does the
work throw in some details and send out
your invite everyone gets the email and
picks from your proposed times tongle
gets it booked and sends it back to your
calendar it even handles time zones and
double
bookings That's The Power of tungle
available now in the App Store